what really stands out lark is just how
sharp how fluid how crisp he has looked
in his last three starts well he put a
lot of work in to get prepared for this
season
i'll be at a late start
and that's his mo
sonny wants to be good at absolutely
everything
this is pulled on the ground and farmer
has it kickoff of him
and i don't know what the heck happened
on that ground ball
we'll see right here
hits it pretty hard i guess i don't oh
that hit off the runner buster posey
didn't i think he could hit the glove
first otherwise buff
lined into center field and it's over
the head of india
[Applause]
so buster had a late jump that's going
to load the bases for crawford that's
some action here in the top of the first
so crawford will hit with the bases
loaded he's two for eight
hit up the middle could be a pair no he
flips it over everybody
and coming in to score is just but he's
out at the plate
the ball hit really hard off the bat at
crawford sonny gray tips it just enough
to india but then he boxes it then he
throws it over the head of of eugenio
suarez yaskremsky being extremely
aggressive
that
right spike plants into the
into the ground
into the
knee of
barnhart here on the mound for the
giants tonight will be logan webb making
his seventh start this season he's
coming off one of his better starts
against the rangers he's two and three
with the four seven four and thirty
eight innings pitched 43 strikeouts
nice swing a smash caught on a bounce by
dubon at second and the throw to first
in time for the out great backhand pick
mauricio duvonne
robs senzel and takes one away that is a
great sign
from senzel staying behind the baseball
can't control it all you can do is hit
it hard
so now basic could mean an rbi for
wilmer flores the giants with a
one-nothing lead here in the fourth
inning
that is hit well
deep right still going adios pelota
three run opposite field home run
for wilmer flores here at the
very
cozy great american ballpark
and you mentioned homer
three-nothing lead giants
now you mentioned it one run will
probably not hold up and three runs may
not hold up either but it's
it's a good couple out on runs and a
great swing in the bat by wilmer flores
who has been struggling at the plate as
of late
does a nice job with that 94
mile-an-hour two-seam fastball from
sunny grade
you just wanted to wait out ground ball
to second tough play backhand pick india
throw off line and the pirouette tag
from farmer nicely done by both
infielders well i think india is much
better
on the move
you see right there and farmer
coming off the bag remember a throw
earlier pulled him off the bag so
fairly aware
that he's got plenty of time
comes off the bag and applies a tag
long term
got to score a little early right like
you can't live late all the time no
matter how good your offense is oh
that's a good play
running throw nick senzelle his second
career start at third base in the big
leagues and he makes a big league play
well he's waiting for that ground ball
to come at him and
mention the ability of india playing on
the run well this is nick zinzell on the
run athleticism good play and the right
man hit it too
not a burning buster posey down the line
so no
need to rush yaz has had a single an
infield hit and a slide out to center
the pitch
swinging a high fly ball to right hit
very well
it is out of here
[Applause]
yastremski does it again it's home run
number six
and the giants lead four nothing
it comes on a 3-2 pitch
and he hit it
almost in the same spot
as he hit the one yesterday in
pittsburgh
except the one in pittsburgh was more of
a line drive this one he hit very high
ended up about 15 rows back
in right center field two down nobody on
here is dubon who's over two three into
the count
that ball is smoked
deep left center field way back there
marios pelota
[Applause]
with a home run to make it five to
nothing the third home run of the game
for the giants
well the giants continue to hit for
power on the road
we talked about de bond being nervous
right there well didn't look too nervous
on that swing
in the national league
for knocking in runs
the change up
see you later that was nasty there and
to your point i think he'd like that 2-1
pitch back again because you don't want
to have to hit this one
this is logan webb's best pitch
best strikeout pitch to left-handers a
change-up that looks like a fast ball
and that's how they're losing games
got him swinging on a ball that ended up
way off the outside and
suarez walks away from the play that
he's
he's kind of steaming right now
certainly after miley's no hitter
you can feel that reverence
hard ground ball for sinzell challenged
again the bare hand one foot and throw
nick sends out sensational at the hot
corner
buster posey might want to stop trying
nick since hell at third base proper
play
bare hand nice stretch from farm at
first base
2-0
that is rocked into left center field
stevenson given the wave by house ball
gathered by talkman
stevenson scores and the reds on the
board 5-1 jesse winker connects again
and i told him it counts it counts as
much as yours buddy oh that's a big rip
by flores
beats senzel in third who comes up
limping some the ball gathered by winker
he fires to second india tag lee
so he slides in safe does he come off
the bag he does hop off the back while
the tag is applied on his hip
out
and they got slater picked off stain it
stay in it stay in it now
now
[Applause]
so rough
[Applause]
scored
give us a chance to win a ball game
starts with that first man getting on
sends that one opposite way outfielders
have been shallow that ball is deep and
it's gone home run tyler naquin the
comeback begins now
everyone in the league knows
how this club has been able to win ball
games from coming from behind
[Applause]
a pitch out over the plate
base is empty one out the reds have
scored a run on a home run by tyler
naked still down four
high fly deep left talkman watches does
it carry
yes back to back jacks
[Music]
6-3
well john well well well here we are
again
[Music]
as i mentioned it's a culture
and geno knew good and well
that he got all that one giants with a
6-3 lead as we go to the bottom of the
ninth inning tyler rogers comes in
popped him up
slater says i got it and he does and
that's the ball game and the giants take
game one